(speaking foreign language)
(soft music)
- [Narrator] Sant'Antioco, Sardinia
is home to a rare artisan,
thought to be the only
person left in the world
to weave sea silk, a rare fiber harvested
from the saliva of a
species of endangered clams
that live here on the ocean floor.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] For more
than a thousand years
the techniques of collecting
and weaving sea silk
have been passed down through her family,
making Chiara the 28th generation.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] The ancient process of diving
to harvest the silk from
the clams is kept a secret
for fear of environmental damage.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] Chiara uses a secret formula
to soak the thread and uses her voice
to activate the mixture.
Thus allowing it to shine like gold.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] Bound by a sacred sea oath,
Chiara how vowed to make
any money from her work.
(speaking foreign language)